Over this weekend, we surpassed a
major covid vaccination milestone
and we came very close to surpassing another. On
Saturday, the US injected two point nine million
vaccines into people's arms, almost half a million
more than the previous single day record of about
two point four million vaccines in a day. And
we are just shy of three million vaccines a day.
That is a real possibility. In the three days
this past weekend, Friday, Saturday, Sunday,
more than seven point seven million vaccines
were injected in just three days. These are
the types of numbers that will turn the
pandemic around if they can be sustained.
Look at how quickly this has ramped
up. When Donald Trump left office,
the seven day average of vaccinations was 890000
a day, thanks to Joe Biden working with Pfizer
and Moderna to ramp up supply to states and
getting the vaccine to states. Importantly,
because we had this situation under Trump where
Pfizer and Moderna were reporting deliveries,
and yet hospitals and clinics were saying we don't
have the vaccines. So that has been improved. We
now have the addition of a third vaccine. We
may have a fourth vaccine. We are now averaging
two point one six million doses per day. Over
the last week. We have a new high water mark of
two point nine million vaccines in a single day.
Right now, by percentage, the leading states on
vaccination are New Mexico, Alaska, Connecticut,
the Dakotas, Rhode Island and Massachusetts.
States doing the worst on vaccination percentage
wise are Georgia, Washington, D.C., which isn't
a state, Alabama, Texas, Utah and Tennessee. I
believe that in the next week, possibly Saturday,
that seems to be the big vaccination day. Every
week we will get to three million vaccines in a
single day. And if you can make that study, you
are dramatically improving the timeline on herd
immunity compared to just doing a million vaccines
that you are. You are moving it up, in fact,
by two thirds. The math of this is that if we can
accelerate to about three million doses per day,
we are looking at maybe three months until we
start getting into the range of what we would
consider to be herd immunity. Could be could be
three. Could be four, could be two and a half.
You know, if we get to four million doses a day,
we could really get even closer. It's not worth
calculating it with too much precision. There's no
sense in saying May 10th will be the day, does it?
You know that things change and shift. But when
you think about three and a half million a day,
that's two hundred and ten million doses in
60 days. If you assume 80 percent of those
are the two shot regimen and the rest are the one
shot, you're maybe looking at fully vaccinating
one hundred and twenty five million people in
the next two months. Thirty million are already
vaccinated. And then that means that like maybe
one more month, you know, 90 days from now, we are
starting to get into the range. Of herd immunity
now there's tons of work to be done, we're racing
against variants against which the vaccines are
not quite as effective in terms of preventing
illness, preventing disease altogether, but very
effective at preventing serious disease, disease
and hospitalization and death. So there's there's
still a lot going on here. And in the next couple
of days, the CDC will put out new guidelines for
vaccinated people. I expect that reading that
will encourage more people to want the vaccine.
It's anticipated the CDC will say it's fine for
vaccinated people to gather indoors in small
groups with no masks. I my thought is that
as people start to see these vaccines actually do
have an impact on not only the nationwide numbers,
but what you can do, that more and more people are
going to want the vaccine. And as soon as the CDC
puts out those guidelines, we will have
them for you. A very exciting on March 26th,
we are going to be doing our next single day
membership special. We haven't done one of these
for months. I wish I could tell you there was some
really exciting reason why we're doing it. The
reason we're doing it is February was the worst
month in more than a year. From the standpoint
of membership's, the economic situation has led
to a lot of people having to cancel memberships.
February being only twenty eight days, left
literally fewer days for people to sign up.
February was a disastrous month for us as far
as memberships go. So we are going to have a one
day huge membership blowout Friday, March 26th.
If you want to be notified about this membership
special, just get on my mailing list
at David Pakman dot com real easy.
And then a Friday morning, March twenty
sixth, you will get a perfect email
with a spectacular coupon code telling you exactly
how to sign up at what is close to an illegal
discount. It's certainly an immoral discount.
It may even be illegal in some states,
but don't worry, nobody's going
after anybody for this stuff.
So get on the newsletter mailing
list at David Pakman dot com.